[Musique]
salut brut série laisse ça fait à peu
près là deux mois que sur los angeles
pour finir des projets musicaux
mais depuis une semaine environ le maire
de la ville il a décrété le confinement
obligatoire pour tous les habitants
c'est à dire que tous les lieux publics
sont fermés type fitness ou alors encore
studio d'enregistrement et du coup on a
fait ce studio dans le carde bnb
du coup la ja le studio est là il ya
voilà remplacer la save tuque ont fait
un petit tour rapide du studio gilles pc
comme d'habitude deux petites enceintes
bon c'est pas le top du top mais ça fait
large d'affaires et la carte sont
pareils un fou je la change parce
qu'alain peut claquer mais ça fait pas
faire toujours j'ai utilisé le carton d
ensemble pour faire imprimer un support
faut que les enceintes soient hauteur
des oreilles en général pour du mix
cette installation rustique tout seul
tout seul je suis avec terence de
confier mon ami d'enfance et qui à la
tête de ricin days il ya les actifs du
coup la cale du coup j'étais en studio
avec le beatmaker twenty nine il ya
environ deux semaines on a commencé à
travailler sur un son est bon moi je
vais l'enregistrer ici du coup y'a
l'instru il manque les paroles c'est
parti
[Musique]
j'avais le soutien aux gens venez
portugais
ah oui je connais des photographies le
même genre fait une loi lâche tatillon
mais on sait jamais un enfant oisif un
niveau vous adam a donné tort
ça arrive une fois sur deux c'est une
fois toutes les cinq minutes
[Musique]
quand général j'écoute quand j'écoute
l'instru georges et plein plein d'idées
qui fusent et j'aime bien baron plus
jamais d'aller capter mais j'enregistre
au téléphone ce que je fume n 1 et après
je sais de vraiment c'est un petit
puzzle qui essaie de mettre en place au
fur et à mesure l'homme tout ça c'est
toutes les prises que j'ai fait
quand bak
bah ouais voilà président oui j'essaie
d'égaliser la voie à faire en sorte
qu'elles qu'elles se marient mieux avec
l'instru sans trafic et la voiture gens
je jouais avec les fréquences met un peu
plus d'aigus couper un peu plus très
grave et de rien que ça ça ça rend plus
agréable que j'écoute
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment refait une prise plus
aiguë âge j'ai découpé pour faire en
sorte que tu vois là cette ligne là à la
gauche de l'oreille
cette ligne là à la droite cette ligne
là à la gauche le russe est une la halle
à droite aussi et ça genre ça enrichit
graveleux le bail qui ça fait bientôt
cinq six ans qu'on est dessus dernière
écoute
[Musique]
voilà ce que cette histoire de
confinement et tout ce qui va s'ensuivre
je pense qu'il faut pas subir mais il
faut s'adapter et là c'est le moyen
parfait pour moi m'adapter parce que
j'ai en fait assez à l'aise dans le fait
d'être tout le temps chez soi à
travailler j'ai travaillé de ce que j'ai
construit ce que j'ai fait dans ma
chambre et donc du coup ça fait un peu
un retour aux sources avec aussi un peu
plus de 2 d'ouverture sur comment le
monde fonctionne de la musique est en
fait des fois ça permet de se recentrer
encore une fois c'est l'occasion de
finir des sons de de commencer de
nouvelles choses pourquoi avoir en fait
c'est le fait d'être seul avec ce n'est
pas forcément négatif et pour toujours
encore une fois pas subir mais s'adapter
parce qu'en fait c'est la seule chose